JAKE ARCHIBALD: Good
morning, everyone.
Welcome to the offline
part of the day.
So my involvement with all the
offline stuff started a year
and a half ago when
I joined Lanyard.
And when I joined Lanyard--
so can everyone hear me?
Right, OK.
I'll stay at this level.
So a year and a half ago,
I started at Lanyard.
When I started, they were
building an iPhone app.
And they were doing this mainly
just to get a presence
in the App Store, but also
because it gave them the
opportunity to make data
available offline.
And offline is important to
conference delegates because
you're quite often on a plane
on the way there, so you've
mostly got no connection
there.
Or when you arrive in a foreign
country, you might be
data roaming.
So we don't want you to have to
pay a lot of money just to
find out where the conference
is or what the sessions are.
And even when you're at the
conference, obviously
conferences have Wi-Fi.
But it's a special brand of
Wi-Fi known as conference
Wi-Fi, which is like Wi-Fi,
but it doesn't work.
So you can't rely on
the connection.
But obviously not everyone
has an iPhone.
People have lots of different
kinds of devices.
And we wanted Lanyard to
work on there as well.
But most of these, quite a few
of these don't have an app
platform, and we didn't have the
resource to go and build
apps for all of then either.
So we wanted to make a web
version of the app, and that
was what I was there to do.
And when I was given this task,
I was like, well, I
really want to work offline
work in the
web version as well.
And I had this recollection of
this thing called AppCache.
And I went and did some
preliminary research into it.
And it looked really good.
I could just add a
reference to a
manifest on the HTML elements.
And I could just list
all the stuff that I
want to work offline.
And it works.
And I could also capture a set
of URLs, like everything that
begins with avatars-- images,
avatars-- and then say, well,
if you're offline, I want you
to serve that instead.
And I was like, wow,
this sounds like
a really good solution.
It seemed like the API was this
big, cuddly teddy bear.
And I kind of ran up and I
hugged the teddy bear and
thought, together, we're going
to get through this.
We can make the web
work offline.
Of course it soon became obvious
that the lovely teddy
bear that I was cuddling
was filled with
razor blades and bees.
And I got stung many,
many times.
And the razor blades
dug into my skin.
And I got the whole alphabet
of hepatitis.
And it was a really
nasty experience.
So you hear the word "gotcha"
a lot with AppCache.
And the spec does seem
to do the unexpected.
MALE SPEAKER: I think
your mic is on.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Ah, yeah.
That would help.
OK.
Oh, that's nicer.
OK, so when something is cached,
it will always come
from the cache.
If the AppCache has something to
give you, it will serve it
straight from the cache.
And so even if you're online,
you're going to get those
cached assets.
And the cache is only updated
if the manifest file itself
changes, just a character
changes, even if that
character is inside a comment.
And the cache only updates if
all of the things you listed
downloads successfully.
If one of them 404s or 500s,
then the whole thing fails.
I started drawing this diagram
to try and make sense of what
AppCache was actually doing,
what the flow of information
was, how it worked.
And I did some talks based on
this, and I'm showing this
diagram, going, look--
look how terrible
that cache is.
Look how complicated it is.
But if you think about some code
you've written recently--
even something fairly simple,
like, I don't know, form
validation--
if you drew it as
a flow chart, it
would look like this.
It would look this complicated,
probably more
complicated.
And that doesn't
make it wrong.
And that doesn't make it
difficult to read.
And that doesn't make
it hard to maintain.
A lot of the gotchas that
AppCache has are actually
quite sensible.
So the cache is used even if
you're online, and that
happens because it's really,
really fast.
The exception is in fallback.
So if it tries to request an
avatar, it's going to go to
the network.
And it's only going to
serve this if the
network request fails.
And that's really quick, in this
case, because you can go
and get the avatar from the
network, and that's going to
be really fast.
It's even faster in this case
because it's going to fail
really, really quickly.
And you'll get the fallback
avatar instead.
The problem case is this,
which I like to
call the real world.
And when your phone's in this
kind of state, it's like a
one-legged dog.
It thinks it can still play
fetch, but it can't.
And you have to watch it drag
itself along the floor with
its one leg.
And it's heartbreaking.
And with your phone it's really,
really irritating.
Because you know that on the
device, on there is the data
that is good enough
for you right now.
But it won't give you it.
It has to wait for minutes
before it decides it really
can't make this connection.
The spec doesn't really mention
offline very much.
It only talks about connections
that succeeded or
failed, all past tense.
It doesn't try and predict
the state of the network.
So cached data at first is good,
because it doesn't have
any expectation of the network,
and that's great.
And that's how apps behave.
If you open Twitter on
your phone, you've
got old data there.
And then it goes and fetches new
data if it can, if there's
a network connection.
So complexity isn't
the problem here.
What is the problem?
Well, what is the AppCache
made of?
There's a request cache.
And we can add, remove, and
update items from this.
And those updates are
transactional.
It's all atomic.
And it's pretty sensible.
There's also a router.
The router takes a network
connection and decides what it
should do with it.
So it can just serve stuff
straight from the cache
without going to network, or
it can go to network, give
that a go, and serve something
from the cache if that fails.
And that's all quite
sensible as well.
But what's our API into this?
Our API is the manifest.
So if I do this, I add
an empty manifest--
well, just with the words
cache manifest--
what this will do is it'll take
index.html and it will
put that into the cache.
And it will set up a routing
rule that says if that page is
requested, serve it straight
from the cache.
Really?
Did I just tell it to
do all that, just
with this empty file?
Here I'm adding a lot more
static routes, and here I'm
saying, hey, with this one line,
take fallback PNG, make
that a cache entry, put
that into the cache.
And if any of these URLs are
requested, set up a routing
rule, try and fetch it from the
network first, and if that
fails, then use this instead,
fallback PNG.
And a failure means any HTTP
status code that starts with
4, 404, anything that starts
with 5, or if there's a
redirect to another domain.
Did I really tell it to do
that with this one line?
That's a lot of assumptions
to make.
And if I, say, have on my HTML
page a link, an image to a
picture of your cat from
Flickr-- do you have a cat?
Who has a cat?
Your cat-- good, Bruce's cat.
What happens to the
image of that cat?
OK, so an index.html file
is a get request.
That's fine.
Is it associated with manifest?
Yes it is.
We're going to use that.
Is the URL AppCached?
Yes it is.
So it comes straight
from the cache.
That's fine.
Is it HTML?
Yes it is.
So for each get request on
the page, we're going
to go back up here.
And that's going to include
the picture of your cat.
So is the URL AppCached?
No.
Is the URL in the network
section of the manifest?
No.
Does the URL match a
fallback prefix?
No.
We've got one for avatars
but not one for
Bruce's cat, so no.
Is there a star in the
network section?
No.
So the image will fail.
And the picture of Bruce's
cat will not appear.
It will appear as if there
was no network.
Even if you're online, the
picture of that cat will fail
to download.
There is nothing here to me that
suggests that picture of
Bruce's cat should not load.
I don't know what the AppCache
has against Bruce's cat, but
even online it's not
going to work.
This is a downfall API.
And by downfall, I don't mean
the shouty Hitler thing.
I'm not suggesting AppCache
is like Hitler--
although it is a bit.
No, I mean the old board game.
I don't know how people have
played this, but this is what
I feel like when I'm dealing
with AppCache.
I know what I'm trying to do.
I'm trying to get my pieces
to the bottom.
And I have a very limited set
of controls for that.
But when I'm doing this, all
kinds of shit's happening in
the background.
And I don't know what's going
on until bits start falling
out of the bottom that
I didn't expect.
And I don't know which of my
actions actually contributed
to that happening.
I know the last one that
happens, but I don't
everything that happened
before that.
The manifest is simple in terms
of the character count,
but there's too much implicit
going on here.
A better API may involve more
typing but might set out
exactly what's supposed
to happen.
What if in your HTML you could
say, I want to register a
JavaScript controller.
This controllers going to take
care of all URLs on the
origin, just slash-star.
And here's my JavaScript file.
And that was going to run
in some kind of worker.
And here I could just say, so
for all these files, when the
cache is supposed to update
itself, I want you to define a
cache called static, and I want
you to cache all of those
static URLs and do
it atomically.
And then when there's a request,
I want you to have a
look and see in the static cache
if there's something
that matches the incoming URL.
And if there is a resource,
prevent default.
Don't do the default
browser action.
Respond with that resource
from the cache.
This is a lot more typing than
the equivalent that you did in
the manifest, but it's
really explicit.
You're setting up exactly
what you want to happen.
There's no magic here.
You can define your own magic.
This is a bring your
own unicorn API.
You do all that stuff
yourself.
What if I could say, OK, I'm
going to set up a route for
get requests.
Anything that starts with
avatars, prevent the default.
I want you to try and get
it from the network.
But on an error, I want you to
see if we've got something,
the fallback PNG in
the resource.
And if there is, I'm
going to serve it.
So that's the equivalent of
your fallback, but you're
telling it exactly what to do.
What if I could listen to
messages from the web page
that's happening?
So imagine something like DFT,
where there's issues.
And the user might have said,
I want to cache this issue.
So he posted a message saying,
cache the issue.
And [INAUDIBLE]
receives that, caches define
issue, and then the issue
number, and the URLs
to cache for that.
And then when those requests
come in, anything that's URL
issue and a number, we're
going to deal with that.
We're going to say get me the
cache for that issue.
If we have that cached and we
have a URL inside that cache
that matches what's being
requested, serve it.
Otherwise, if the request type
is a navigate, as in, someone
is changing page, it's going to
be a full reload, prevent
the default.
Respond--
try and fetch it from the
network as normal.
And if that fails, and the
status code was zero, which
suggests a lack of network
connection, then serve a thing
from the cache saying, no, I'm
afraid you don't have that
issue cached, here's why.
And that's something we can't
do with AppCache now.
Maybe you could do stuff like
get stuff from local storage
and then use Mustache to
render it, or whatever
templating language
you included.
We could just completely build
an app up from this experience
and completely define how
it should behave.
So even someone who is
unfamiliar with the API would
have a good idea of
what it's doing.
They wouldn't have to read a
whole spec to understand
what's going on.
What if we could do that?
And I think that's what we're
going to discuss, or
things around it.
I don't how this transition--
you have to clap.
[APPLAUSE]
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Watch
out, watch out.
I think that's Andrew's
seat, isn't it?
ANDREW BETTIS: Right.
So I realized when Jake started
that I completely
forgot to big up all
the people on the
panel before we started.
So we have Jake, who's obviously
just given his talk.
He's now developed relations
for Google,
formerly from Lanyard.
Mark Christian from Twitter,
who also created one of the
first informative sites about
AppCache, appcachefaqs.info.
Alex Russell, also from Google,
who is co-author of
the proposal that Jake was just
talking about, with the
navigation controller.
And Jonas Sicking from Mozilla,
who has very kindly
signed up at the very last
minute to replace [INAUDIBLE]
Tobie Langel, who's
unfortunately unable to make
it because he's ill.
So let's get started.
So we have loads of questions
in moderator about offline.
And I think the most burning
one for me, and I think the
one that's most relevant to
DFT is why is there such a
constraint on what we
can do offline?
Why do we have such tiny limits
on what we can store?
And is this a problem that we
need to solve at the spec
level, or do we need an entire
new technology to solve it?
Jake, why don't you start?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: OK, so if you're
building something,
it's going to be running
on multiple devices.
So you can't make too many
expectations of the amount of
data that you would be able to
store on a particular device.
That said, one of the things
we were looking at is the
ability to request a
permanent cache.
Because one of the problems
we've got with the current
cache is the browser may
object at any point.
Has my microphone
gone off again?
Oh, whatever.
So the browser can just get
rid of it at any point.
Oh, hello.
So what AppCache gives you is
it says, one of these assets
is not going to be ejected
from the cache.
If anything's going to be
ejected, they're all going to
be ejected together.
And the spec doesn't say that
this stuff's going to be
around forever.
So the idea is if we could
make it where you would
request a permanent cache, maybe
of a particular size,
then you could do
that and that.
And because a user would agree
to give you that, they are
also now in control of
uninstalling something.
So if there is a lack of space,
like they run out of
space on their phone, then it's
down to them to decide
what to keep and what to lose.
So they might go and say, well,
this small FT app is
very important to me, whereas
these big game apps are not.
And it's their decision
of what to do?
ANDREW BETTIS: So what's the
limit on what's reasonable?
What's reasonable for an app
to acclaim for its own
exclusive use?
ALE RUSSELL: How is
that a question
for the app to answer?
It's usually a question for
the user to answer.
This is about the user agent
mediating the conversation
between the app developer and
the user, who is the owner of
the device.
And so you're trying to enable
that conversation to happen in
an informed way.
And usually that doesn't
mean, can I
have some bit of storage.
It's usually did I mean
to install this thing?
Did I mean to turn this into
a real thing that's not an
ephemeral page that I happen
to load and unload.
The question is, have my
expectations been violated by
navigating naked
to a web page.
Did that imply that
100 megabytes was
taken on disk per page?
If I'm going to Facebook every
day, maybe it does.
Maybe that's a reasonable
thing to do.
If I go to Twitter and I like
to see all my history, maybe
that's the most reasonable
thing I
could possibly imagine.
But that's a decision that
I as a user should be
at least part of.
And so today we don't have
that way to mediate it.
And so I [INAUDIBLE]
there was an additional proposal
yesterday that Jonas
and others at Mozilla were
working on to layer on top of
this API that we have shown a
little bit of, the idea of a
more declarative manifest that
has more to say about what the
thing is that you would
take an action on.
JONAS SICKING: There's
a few things here.
First of all, you shouldn't
think of the web as being
different from native
applications.
Native applications, once you
install a native application,
it can write as much
as it wants.
Why should the web not be able
to do that, assuming the
user's fine with it.
So we need to have some way of
communicating between the
application and the user that
the user thinks this website
is important and then wants to
enable it to store data on the
local device.
So that is really something
we would need to enable.
Google actually has some
interesting ideas here in the
[INAUDIBLE]
API, where they have this
concept of temporary storage
and permanent storage.
That concept is something we
are working on expanding so
you can use that storage area to
store essentially anything
that you can store locally, you
can choose to [INAUDIBLE]
store permanently
or temporary.
And the user can then
be involved.
And we can also use heuristics
in the browser.
Like, if we know that the user
is using a website a lot, we
can grant that website more
implicit storage, and we can
be more careful about when
we eject that data.
Or we can also enable the
website to say, I want to
really lock this down.
And then once the user's OK with
that, we can guarantee
that certain data is
available offline.
So the goal should really be
that anything that native
applications can do when it
comes to sorting data locally,
the web should be able to do.
And that shouldn't be
hard to accomplish.
ANDREW BETTIS: Is it currently
a problem that a user giving
explicit consent to store
something as an explicit
intention to store, but
then the browser can
implicitly purge it?
Is that a bug, do you think,
currently in implementation?
Should it be the case that
anything that's explicitly
given permission to be stored
should be explicitly removed
by the user?
JONAS SICKING: I think we need
to enable the scenario where
you're guaranteed that
something is wrong.
The only way to guarantee that
something is wrong is to take
up storage on the user's device,
which means taking
resource away from the user.
And so the user needs to be
involved in that decision.
But in many cases, you don't
need that level of guarantee.
And you could probably build
pretty good heuristics so that
things mostly work without
the user being involved.
But I also think that we need
to enable websites to say,
hey, I really want to be able to
guarantee this to the user,
in which case we can
have interaction.
We can have a security
dialogue.
But as long as we make that
flow nice and don't ask--
like Firefox currently does,
asks you three times before it
grants you that permission.
It should be within the control
of the website when to
ask the user.
And it should only
be one question.
The user should just say, yeah,
I'm OK with giving this
website a little bit
more information.
And we shouldn't need to ask
about individual [INAUDIBLE].
ANDREW BETTIS: So can
I just a quick poll?
Who here has run out of space
when they were building an
offline app?
So we have a few
people who've--
OK, interesting.
ALEX RUSSELL: I think it's
also a UX issue.
There's the what is it
that I'm doing here?
Are we going to ask users
honestly to go reason about
their storage independently of
what the application is?
I don't think that people,
generally speaking-- certainly
not the app platform models
that we have today--
I don't think people reason
about them independently.
You have an application, and
that means that you have its
data as well.
And we don't really have a
reified idea of what an
application is.
That's the thing that we don't
have, as a unit of something
that we can communicate
to end users today.
And Mozilla's building an app
platform, and we're building
an app platform.
And they helped unify
that concept.
And it feels to me like
helping to make that
transition from I've got a page
to look, it's also an
application--
I think that's really the big
transition for everyone who's
building apps, both conceptually
as you're
building them and for users
who are consuming them.
I'd like to talk more at some
point about what it means to
transition as a builder thinking
about an app--
ANDREW BETTIS: Well, your
microphone's not working.
So next time you want to speak,
just let me know.
And you can speak into mine.
MALE SPEAKER: His
mic works fine.
But he can't talk over his
shoulder to Andrew.
He's got to talk directly
[INAUDIBLE].
ALEX RUSSELL: Sorry
about that.
MARK CHRISTIAN: So I think that
part of the problem with
the situation right now is that
web applications feel a
little bit different than
websites, but they're all
running in the same universe.
And when you're building an
application, you want to have
quite a bit of control over
how you're storing your
resources and managing the
user data, whereas
historically, web APIs have been
more like suggestions to
the user agent.
It's up to the user agent to
interpret what's going on and
deal with it appropriately.
AppCache demonstrates that
there's a lot of assumptions
built into that that don't
always work, and it makes it
difficult to have a consistent
experience.
So I think part of the problem
is actually philosophical.
As we go forward and build a new
API, how much control do
we want to let these
applications have?
And it's a trust
issue as well.
Going to a random website, how
much trust does that actually
imply that user has?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I think we could
spend the whole of today
trying to work out what the
difference between a website
and a web app is.
And I think at the end of it,
we'd say, well, does it
actually matter?
Once we've made that decision,
what would we do differently?
So I think this API we're making
now would work fine for
sites and work fine for apps.
What do you see as the
difference between the two?
MARK CHRISTIAN: Probably
persistence of storage and
amount of storage.
Those are the characteristics.
Do you want a random website to
be able to dump a gigabyte
of data onto your hard drive?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Well, I might
if it's Wikipedia.
I might want to download
Wikipedia as a site.
MARK CHRISTIAN: Yeah,
I might too.
But there's no good model for
letting a user illustrate that
that's actually what
they really wanted.
JONAS SICKING: I think one
problem we have is that
historically websites have been
these things where, as a
browser, we treat them as--
we have no idea if this is
something that the user
actually likes.
It might be just some random
website that the user found
through a link in
a spam email.
And so we have this very
distrusting relationship of
the website.
And as we're trying to expand
the web into being able to do
more things, we have to enable
the user to indicate, I
actually trust this website.
I actually enjoy this website.
I want this website to be able
to do things that [INAUDIBLE]
shouldn't be able to do.
So we need some way, some
UX to enable the user to
communicate to the browser that,
hey, it's OK for this
website to get some extra
capabilities.
So one way of doing this is
app platforms that both
Firefox and Chrome OS is having,
which enables the
users to go through this install
flow, at which point,
you indicated that yeah, I trust
this website enough that
I have installed it.
We should enable those
capabilities not just through
install flow but also through
other means where it's still a
website, UX-wise, but you've
indicated some other way that
it's OK for this guy to
use more resources.
The two things in Firefox OS
that we're giving a website
once it's installed is ability
to use resources and ability
to annoy the user.
So on the web, we built
pop-up blockers.
We tried to disable this ability
of disabling the
context menu.
And a lot of the things that
it's really nice if the good
guys can do but we don't want
the bad guys to do.
And so if we can have some way
to use UX to indicate that
this website should be able to
do things, then we can enable
much more [INAUDIBLE].
ANDREW BETTIS: Do you think that
using app runtimes as a
solution to offline problems
is good enough?
Or do you think that we ought
to be able to solve these
problems without using
app runtime?
JONAS SICKING: I think app
runtimes is a good way for us
to experiment, but
it's an easy out.
We have this traditional sense
of what an application is.
And traditional users know what
it means to install an
application, as far as I know
that this enables this
application to do more things.
I shouldn't install
it if I hate it.
So it gives us an easy
out, but it's
definitely not good enough.
There needs to be a fluid
transition from being a
potentially evil spam website
that the user has navigated to
being a fully-trusted
installed app.
It's a smooth transition.
And the user, as you're slowly
getting more and more familiar
with the website, it shouldn't
be a hard path.
It should be, you trust it more
and more, and it gets
more and more capabilities as
the user gives it more and
more trust.
App runtimes is definitely
not enough of an answer.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah, we've been
through that same problem
before with Flash.
I mean, we went for so long with
not adding these APIs to
HTML, saying, oh, if you want
those kind of capabilities, do
it in a plug-in.
And we're seeing the same again
with, oh, if you want
those kind of things, just
do it in an app.
We shouldn't let that stop us
making the platform better.
ANDREW BETTIS: Jake and Alex,
you're proposing actually a
controller that gives the
developer a lot of flexibility
over how they respond to
offline situations.
There's a great question in
Moderator which is, how would
you propose to use that
to handle the
one-legged dog scenario?
ALEX RUSSELL: So I think
the answer to this is--
it's a little bit circuitous,
so stick with me.
The way AppCache works,
generally speaking, when it
works, is to help you take the
shell of an application, the
thing that will load content
and then display it to you
while your offline, package that
up, and make it available
to you at all points.
What Jake showed you was a great
way for you to package
up the shell of a content
application using AppCache.
There's a related question,
which is inflated by the API
of AppCache, unfortunately,
which is, how do I then deal
with the content that I'm
loading inside this shell?
Because every app you
load in native
environment has this duality.
I've got shell, and I've got a
library of content that I'm
navigating.
And if you think about the way
you're building things on the
server, you do exactly
the same thing.
You've got this node graph of
content that you're allowing
users to transition through,
and they're
all mapped to URLs.
But you usually take the little
bit of content that's
unique to that URL, and you
smash a gigantic template
thing around it, and you spit
it all out as a string, and
then you rehydrate it
on the client side.
But that isn't what the URL
is really addressing.
The URL addresses that little
bit of content, that unique
bit of indivisible content
that you're
serving at that URL.
And it may be multiple nodes all
joined into one particular
serialization.
But that's sort of the idea.
So the question is, how do
we enable people to build
application architectures
offline, which easily give you
that shell and the ability to
cache resources which you will
load inside that shell, so that
you can discover them, so
you can load them, you can
provide the fallback
experience if you
don't have them.
Today, AppCache rolls them
all into one manifest.
Because today, if you actually
take the AppCache to its
logical conclusion, what you
realize at the end of this
long, painful journey-- which
Jake took, and which the Gmail
team took, and which a lot of
people who have been building
offline apps have taken
independently--
is that AppCache is the
thing that you use
to cache the shell.
And for all other content, which
you would have liked to
have given a nice URL, what you
do is you build an ad hoc
synchronization protocol, you
put it in Web SQL Database or
IndexDB or local storage.
And then every time someone
navigates to that URL, you try
to override what the browser
was going to do to navigate
you, go get it out of the local
storage if you have it,
and then perform your
own synchronization
on that data model.
So you have a data model which
is not represented at those
URLs anymore.
So the default model is
effectively URL hostile.
And the only thing that's helped
by having it at a URL
is loading the initial shell,
which is the least meaningful
thing in terms of URL space.
So what you'd really like to
do in all this is to help
application owners understand
through the API that your
caching two separate
sets of things.
There's a shell, which is your
browser for your content.
There's the browser that
you browse to different
sites and apps with.
But there's the browser that you
build for the content that
you're surfacing inside
your app.
And then there's the
content of the app.
You need to treat them
independently, but you'd like
them both to be cacheable
as HTTP resources.
So the way to get there is
to change expectations.
There's no app that you're
going to build that's
meaningful that's not
offline by default.
AppCache gets you part of the
way there, because it makes
the resources for your app
shell offline by default.
But it doesn't necessarily do
anything particular for the
resources that you would like
to load inside that shell.
So we have to make this
transition in thinking about
building apps in this world,
which is, we're not building a
series of HTML pages that you're
going to serialize at a
URL fully formed from the server
side as strings that
you're going to put back
into the cache.
It's nonsensical.
It doesn't work.
Instead what you're going to do
is you're going to assume
that there's a shell that's
booted, and you're moving
between the cached resources,
and if you can get to them,
the uncached ones.
And that means that you're
always working from this local
store of your shell and your
content in order to do
everything.
And that's the big transition
that has been conflated with
the use of AppCache over time.
And everyone discovers that
that's what AppCache implies,
but it's not clear.
And it's not clear that that's
how you have to build your
application to be successful.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So I would see
the model working if you
imagine an app--
I think I'm all right.
If you imagine an app--
no, I'm not.
If you imagine an app where it's
a series of messages from
people you're subscribed to--
basically Twitter--
if you visit the page and you
don't have a controller
installed, and you don't have
JavaScript, the server is
going to construct all
of this stuff.
You'll have to wait for a
network who responds, and
you'll get it how internet
should work today.
If you have a controller
installed, it's going to
respond with an empty content
shell of the UI, it's going to
kick off an XHR or request on
your page, but it's going to
have a header or query
strings saying, I'm
OK with cached data.
The controller is going to
see that and return the
last data you saw.
You're going to build
up the page.
And that's going to
happen instantly.
But then it will set off another
XHR, something in a
query string, saying, I want
this data to come from online.
And that connection will either
succeed, in which case
you'll replace the content on
the screen with the new stuff,
or it will fail, and you'll
fail silently.
And that's your offline
experience.
ANDREW BETTIS: Can I pick up--
you were talking about the
failure scenario of trying to
load content and then it failing
and falling back to
content from cache.
So the biggest problem we have
with AppCache with the
fallback is that you can't
control that timeout.
You can't determine how long
that's going to be, and it's
usually longer than a user
is prepared to wait.
So in the scenario of using a
navigation controller, in
which you'd be able to configure
what that timeout
is, how long are you
prepared to wait?
ALEX RUSSELL: You have explicit
control under the
controller scenario over
the loading process.
So you are able to make
a decision when you're
dispatching the request in the
first place, do I know that
I'm offline?
The only thing that we can
actually tell you from the
browser's perspective about
your online versus offline
state is that you are
definitively not connected to
any network.
We can't tell you whether or not
you can hit your server.
We can't tell you anything about
what's reasonable in
terms of expectation for
hitting your server.
We can tell you if you're behind
a hostile proxy or
inside of a captive portal
from some Wi-Fi thing.
We can't tell you any of that.
That's going to be up to
your application to
have to figure out.
And the way you do that is by
making one these requests and
then watching what happens.
So yes, you'll be able to cancel
the request and respond
with I have no idea
what's going on.
And it's going to be explicitly
under your control,
which is to say that you'll
explicitly have to provide
that functionality.
But that's a damn sight better
than trying to have to figure
out a way to make AppCache
do it right now.
ANDREW BETTIS: And here's
another quick
question from Moderator.
Is there scope for a standard
way of synchronizing content
from server to client
and vice versa?
JONAS SICKING: So
synchronization is really hard.
Once you get into two-way
synchronization, which is what
you often get into, there's
no standard way of
synchronizing data.
It's very, very application
specific, how you deal with
merged conflicts.
So one answer is simply no,
we can't solve this.
There are some interesting
approaches that may work.
So Couch, for example, does this
thing where it allows you
to synchronize data, but
it doesn't actually
deal with the merging.
So you can pull down data, and
the local data that you end up
with explicitly contains
the conflict.
And then after the fact, once
you run code, then you can
deal with that conflict.
And so potentially we can build
something around that model.
But I think dealing with
synchronization is really,
really hard.
I think in the beginning
we need to just.
ANDREW BETTIS: Are we just
asking for trouble here?
I mean, are we just asking
to build something that
developers will say, that
doesn't quite work the way I
want it to, so I'm going
to build my own?
ALEX RUSSELL: I think the thing
that will get you in
trouble is making assumptions
about the developers' data
model, which were not
collaborative.
So if we provide developers a
data model which we constrain
tightly, like, if we provide
a straight transition chart
system that you can then speak
in high-level terms about the
changes between the states of
your applications, and then we
can watch those in a way that,
say, a SQL database watches
the SQL queries that come in and
the transactions and the
commits and you can then make a
binary log of them, then you
can start to do something about
the synchronization of
the high-level application
semantics.
But as much as people would like
to pretend that HTML is
semantic, it ain't.
HTML today, in most of its use
cases, ain't semantic.
You're not saying anything more
meaningful than div, div,
div, div, div.
And your mutations of HTML are
no more meaningful that show
or hide this particular
piece of UI.
They don't relate specifically,
in most cases,
except in a tangential way, to
I'm changing this particular
piece of state in my data model,
which is what you're
trying to synchronize.
And so we don't have a local
idea of a data model.
Therefore we can't really cons
up the idea of a local
synchronization store.
I think that the next iteration
of the library wars
will be about data models
locally and synchronization.
My guess is that people are
going to start doing
operational transform libraries
out of the woodwork.
It's going to be amazing.
We're starting to see this a
little bit with Meteor and
some other libraries that are
starting to apply some good
computer science to the
question of how do I
differentiate what's happening
when I change it?
How do I prevent merge conflicts
in the first place,
by dealing in high-level
operations, and not in, oh
look, some field was
added or removed?
And we're starting to add good
support for being able to
build these libraries into both
the language and the DOM.
There's something called
object.observe and mutation
observers, which are way of
observing those changes as
they happen and responding to
high-level events and not the
low-level primitives changing
out from underneath you.
But we've got a very long way
collectively to go to get to
an agreement whereby we as
browser vendors would feel, I
think, reasonably comfortable
in blessing one particulars
strategy for describing your
data and then another strategy
for synchronizing it.
ANDREW BETTIS: So has anyone
here implemented any kind of
offline sync, any kind
of ability to
synchronize data to browser?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
ANDREW BETTIS: OK, so what's
your use case?
MALE SPEAKER: It's exactly how
you just described it.
The AppCache hosts the shell,
and everything else comes from
local storage.
So local storage is the user
data, AppCache is the shell.
And it assumes from the
beginning that the user is
going to have no data and then
tries to fetch over an AJAX
request and feeds into
local storage.
MARK CHRISTIAN: I think most
of the problems with
synchronization are less data
model than we would think.
I feel like it's actually
a feasible problem.
If you look at stuff like
iCloud, you can offer a couple
of pretty basic data
strategies.
Like, I've got a key value
store, or I've
got a record store.
You don't need to build up
particularly complex models in
the browser to actually
be able to support--
there's this thing, it has a
GUID, and you can say whatever
the most recent changed
version is works.
ALEX RUSSELL: So you're positing
that one default
strategy across multi-tenant
synchronization will work,
that there's only a single user,
and that user's last
change is going to be
synchronized and timed
correctly across multiple
systems.
And you're saying that there's
a closed form over the
operations that I can take.
You do need the closed form, but
you need the ability for
applications to specify the
operations that they will
allow on their data and what it
means for them to change a
piece of data.
Yes, you can bring users down to
one model of mutating data
and what that semantic
is for mutation.
And you can constrain the set of
things that they will then
reasonably be able to do in
the app without hitting
synchronization issues
based on this policy.
You could do that, but I don't
feel like it's our job as a
platform right now to make that
kind of a call in quite
such a closed way.
Because I don't think that we've
got the experience in
our community for that's
the right thing to do.
I can tell you right now that
that would not work for Gmail.
It honestly would not
work for Gmail.
It wouldn't work for Sync.
It wouldn't have worked
for Wave.
It doesn't work for Plus.
It won't fly.
ANDREW BETTIS: Mark, can you
tell us why Twitter doesn't
currently use offline?
MARK CHRISTIAN: Well, Twitter's
web platform is in a
bit of flux.
We're moving towards
a server as the
ultimate source of truth.
So we actually don't do any
client side rendering at all.
So any navigation event, even
though it's happening AJAXly,
is actually just injecting a
response from the server.
So you can't really cache that
nearly as efficiently as you
could a series of JSON
responses, for example,
because they're full-page
responses.
So not every AJAX model is going
to work as well with
that sort of a strategy.
Whether that changes
in the future, TBD.
But basically, two competing
styles of how you want to have
a fast responsive app, you have
something that lives on
the server, something that lives
entirely on the client.
And having something that can
react to both is actually a
messy, terrible proposition
right now.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: The way we did
that at Lanyard was we were
rendering on the server with
Mustache and some data.
And then when we were doing the
same on the client with
offline, we were using the same
Mustache templates, and
we were caching the same data
model in local storage, the
same as you were.
And obviously we'd rather be
doing that in AppCache.
So yeah, you can still do the
progressive enhancement thing
and have a client-based
app, and you're not
duplicating too much data.
And did anyone see the "B&B"
article recently where they
were talking about, hey, we've
decided to try this new,
exciting idea.
And what we're going to do is
we're going to render content
on the server, and we're
going to send out an
HTML string of content.
And it's amazingly fast.
You guys should all
be doing this.
Yeah, we've been calling that
progressive enhancement.
MARK CHRISTIAN: Well, that's
sort of our model too.
Twitter's famously, remember,
the hashbang website a couple
of years ago.
It was actually pretty speedy
if you were on a MacBook Pro
with the latest version
of Chrome.
But if you were using IE7 in
Bangalore, it was actually an
atrocious experience.
And so the server side model
ends up working a lot better
on the low end.
And the problem with having two
rendering stacks, even if
they're sharing templates, is
that you've got quirks between
your view implementation.
And that is a great way to kill
yourself with 1,000 paper
cuts, especially if you're on
a large dev team with a few
dozen developers trying to
keep it all in sync.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: No, I completely
agree with that.
Because we were using Mustache,
and we ended up
pretty much owning, or making
massive contributions to about
four different implementations
of Mustache the Python one,
the Java one, the IOS one,
and the JavaScript one.
MARK CHRISTIAN: There's one
developer at Twitter who's
single-handedly written
two from scratch--
Hogan and Eckersley--
just because most of the
implementations had
some sort of issue.
ANDREW BETTIS: So are you
saying, then, that the only
real use case for offline
technologies is when you
actually want to build an
offline app rather than to
improve the performance
of your app?
MARK CHRISTIAN: Well,
application versus website--
it's the same thing I
mentioned earlier.
I feel like the offline
technologies are really good
for building an app, like
the Lanyard thing.
But they don't really map very
well towards a Twitter or even
a Wikipedia kind of example.
They just don't feel like a very
good fit for something
where you're always pulling
in new data, and it's an
unbounded amount of content
that you might
want to pull in.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: If you're
just looking to improve
performance, that's what
the HTTP cache is for.
The application cache is for
caching applications--
it's for making it
work offline.
If you can get a performance
benefit out of using it, then
fair enough.
But you are buying into making
an offline-first experience.
ALEX RUSSELL: To be clear,
though, the new proposal would
be a reasonable accelerator.
If you don't ever handle any
navigation events but only
resources, you could certainly
build a local high performance
cache system to improve website
performance without
biting off any offline
capability at all.
ANDREW BETTIS: In what situation
would you want to do
that versus using
the HTTP cache?
ALEX RUSSELL: We've had good
input from the folks at
Facebook that this is their core
use case for AppCache, is
actually making things--
or not a core.
One of their most important use
cases was making things
available faster.
And at Google, I know that our
global teams have had similar
needs, and AppCache
hasn't met them.
So hopefully this new API
will meet those two.
JONAS SICKING: Yeah, I think the
mental model that I've had
recently is that it would be
great if we can make it work
so that the online case
is very similar
to the offline case.
It's more a difference between
are you seeing controller
slash app cache or you're not.
So if we can make it so that
when you are using these new
features for enabling offline
but you happen to be online,
you can still download the data
and just download the
data part and not the template
and the static content and use
that cached version of that
increase performance.
I'm definitely hoping that that
is a model we can get to,
to basically make the online
application experience be more
competitive with native--
where on native you're
downloading your shell once.
And then as you're using it,
you're just downloading the
incremental data.
We should be able to make the
same thing possible on the web
to increase performance.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So the HTTP
cache is like this really busy
room, and everyone's in there.
And the browser's having to be
the bouncer at the door.
And when other people want into
the room, the bouncer's
going, look, you've had
too much to drink.
You should get out.
And then what Facebook have done
is gone, ah, but there's
this quieter bar around
the corner.
We're going to go there.
But the thing is, if everyone
starts doing that, then that
bar is going to have to hire a
bouncer, and they're going to
start kicking people
out as well.
It seems like a nice performance
enhancement now.
But I think if everyone started
using it, we're going
to get the same issues where if
everyone's stuffing fonts
and images into local storage,
there's going to have to be a
bouncer there that kicks
people out-- unless the
website asked for a
permanent cache.
But I don't think we want a
web where you just visit
Facebook because you want to
look at a thing, and it's
saying, Facebook wants to
install 5 megabytes worth of
stuff just so you can see it.
It's not for an offline
experience, it's just to look
at the site.
MARK CHRISTIAN: The interesting
characteristic
about using AppCache for storing
the outer shell is
that it lets you have a cache
where it's totally happy to
start rendering the page with
the old version, without even
going to see if there's
a new one.
And that's something that HTTP
caching could theoretically be
modified to have but doesn't.
And it's an interesting
characteristic all its own.
HTTP caching in general is best
described as bewildering.
There's just so many options,
and it never quite does what
you expect.
And with all of AppCache's
problems, one thing that we
can say is at least we can
expect that the data will be
there when we ask
for it again.
JONAS SICKING: I don't think the
bar around the corner is
necessarily going to get
as packed as the
initial HTTP cache bar.
Because if we are good enough
at building the heuristics
where maybe we don't download
AppCache the first time you
visit a website.
But if we see that you visit a
website every day, then we'll
download the AppCache and we'll
keep it more tightly.
So I think if we're more clever
than we are with HTTP
cache, then I think we
can keep the good
people in that bar.
ANDREW BETTIS: Why do we need
another bar at all?
Just hypothetically, why do we
not just have an extra cache
control directive that gives
enhanced persistence within
the HTTP cache?
ALEX RUSSELL: I try to rephrase
this as, why is there
no priority system?
Why is their no user expressible
and collaborative
priority system?
So many of the cases where we
wind up fighting the browser
as developers are cases where if
we could express our intent
more clearly to the browser, the
browser could collaborate
with the user to have
a better experience
provided in many cases.
We could then use the browser
to help express to the user,
hey, this is what we're
trying to do here.
And if you say to the browser,
listen, these resources are
really dear to me, these are
slightly less dear, and these
are totally ephemeral, I don't
really need them--
the work that the folks are
doing on Quota API for the
file system points in this
direction, where you're
getting to a point where you can
start to collaborate with
the system and say listen, these
are really important to
me, these are less important.
And I don't think we need to
back ourselves into hard
guarantees, as long as we're
able to say that, by default,
you're in the less privileged
group until you ask for a
privilege, in which case you
take on responsibility to
collaborate.
You might be evicted.
You might get events about
whether or not eviction is
about to happen, and maybe you
should offer up some other
thing to remove or try to remove
stuff for yourself.
This is a well-worn path in
a lot of other operating
systems, where you'll say,
hey, dear plug-in or dear
application, we're running
low on storage.
Can you please clean
some stuff up?
Or where the OS tries to clean
things up for you if it winds
up under pressure.
At that point, you have to
have a conversation.
And today we have no way to
have that conversation.
So it's not that we necessarily
need a different
bar or a different bouncer, but
I think those are just one
way of saying we need multiple
levels of collaboration and
cooperation, and we don't have
any of that right now.
MARK CHRISTIAN: This goes to the
philosophical web idea of
the user agent knows best.
Even when we talk about some
of the new ideas, there's
these heuristics on caching.
And we've never really decided
to empower the app developer
to have much of a say in this.
ALEX RUSSELL: Well,
let's be clear.
The user agent is in control.
It may not know best, but it's
certainly in control, because
we're putting users in control
of their system and their
experience.
So the imperative for the user
agent to have the last say is
all about giving users
the last say.
And so that's an inviolable
principle of a safe web.
The answer was, well, shouldn't
we just count on
everyone being nice?
And the answer is,
no, advertisers.
Duh.
MARK CHRISTIAN: It's still a
very different model than
native apps, though.
And I'm not saying it's a
bad model, but it's just
interesting that native apps
don't have the same set of
constraints on them.
Once they're on the app, then
they can do all of these
things within the sandbox.
And in general, the sandbox that
you'll get on a native
platform is very much wider than
the sandbox that you'll
get as a random website.
JONAS SICKING: Yeah, but there's
still a very big
difference from a random website
and a native app.
Within a native app, the user
has made a decision that I
care about this app, at the very
least enough to bother
with download time.
But it's even more to the point
that the user has said,
I trust this website to
do a lot of things.
Most native apps can take
over your system.
So the user has clearly
indicated that there's some
amount of trust.
And so we can't really ever give
the random website that
the user's visiting the first
time the same amount of trust
as a native app has.
But this is where I think this
smooth transition from going
from untrusted to trusted
needs to happen.
ANDREW BETTIS: Is it ever
reasonable that you could
visit a random website and it
could prompt you saying, this
website wants to completely take
over your computer, do
you want to allow this?
ALEX RUSSELL: Sure, we
have that today.
JONAS SICKING: I don't think we
should have the question to
the user, click the yes button
if you want your system
entirely taken over, click
the no button if not.
Because some people will click
the yes button not knowing
what their doing.
So we need to be more
careful than that.
ALEX RUSSELL: I like to think
about this as what are you
getting back for friction?
So in native apps, there's
much more friction to
discovery and use.
I have to know that I want it
or be told that I want it or
be advertised to as something I
should want and then go buy
it off the friction of
finding this thing.
Whereas the web has this amazing
model where there's a
zero friction to navigate
and use a new thing.
Identity is a problem.
We've got a lot of other things
which add incidental
friction over time, but
generally speaking, we have
paid application developers back
1,000 fold for putting
something on the web by reducing
the friction to using
to almost nothing.
And native app models induce
this friction.
And I think that Jonas is
entirely correct that that
smooth transition needs to get
you to a point where in order
to get the same capabilities
that you would give to a
native app, you have to have
the same level of friction.
Because the constraints that you
impose at those points are
reasonable, and both sets of
system authors have made
choices about which constraints
are going to
impose at each level of friction
under all the same
considerations.
They're saying, if you browse to
an ephemeral web page, then
you get whatever level
of effort you put
into browsing there.
And if you install something,
you get maybe more privilege
and more process available
to you.
And I think that's
the right model.
And so yeah, I think that's
going to be the endpoint, is
well, it will have that
much friction.
And having that much friction
will get you that much.
MARK CHRISTIAN: The smooth
gradient's a really
interesting model.
But I just think that as we're
designing new APIs, we should
make sure that we actually try
to figure out, what does that
smooth gradient look like?
And how can we make the APIs
flexible enough to have a
difference between it's either
working completely or it
doesn't work at all?
ANDREW BETTIS: I think we should
probably move on and
talk about what we can do today
rather than what we
should be doing tomorrow.
So one of the most popular
questions we have is--
a lot of people are stuffing
fonts, images, and JavaScript
in local storage for
fasting loading.
Should we be discouraging
this, which is something
[INAUDIBLE]
was saying at [INAUDIBLE]
and us as well.
So what would you say
to that, Alex?
ALEX RUSSELL: Is it
working for you?
If so, go for it.
I mean, I come from a dirty
JavaScript hacker background.
Man, if it works, run.
Run with it as far as it goes.
But measure.
Measure, measure, measure.
If it's actually faster,
heck yes.
Make the web faster.
Go, do it.
ANDREW BETTIS: So do we need
to be aware of what pain
that's storing up for
us in the future?
And how much pain is that
storing up for us in future?
ALEX RUSSELL: A lot.
So let me tell you
all about it.
So you'll notice if you're
stuffing a lot of stuff into
local storage that you'll see
some really strange behavioral
differences between IE9 and 10,
and Firefox and Chrome,
with regards to potentially
getting out of sync across
tabs or across Windows with
regards to try to communicate
over a local storage.
Well, why is that?
Local storage is a
synchronous API.
This is generally speaking in
terms of web API design a
terrible, terrible thing.
This is a bad thing.
It's the reason that IndexDB
is coming along--
which is available, I think, in
IE10 and it's available in
Chrome and it's coming along
in other places, too.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Another
terrible, terrible thing.
ALEX RUSSELL: I know.
It's harder to use, right?
So that was the pain.
So that pain generated this new
system which isn't widely
enough deployed yet.
And so folks find out that
there's an implicit cross tab
synchronization issue with local
storage because the API
is synchronous for all the tabs
that can see the same
local store.
This isn't great.
This is actually relatively
terrible.
So we need an asynchronous
version of local storage.
So one of these you're biting
off is a huge performance
issue because you'll start
loading your web page, you'll
ask local storage early in the
document load to go grab you
some resource, and you
think it's fast.
Except we're brand
new to this.
We might have put this in a
SQLite database on a per local
store or per origin basis.
We have to go do synchronize IO
to go load that database,
block that web page, by the way,
while we're doing this,
block the main thread, go do a
bunch of IO, and then give you
the answer.
This is terrible for
performance.
ANDREW BETTIS: OK, so I get it.
I get it.
It's painful.
So should we just not do it
and wait for this amazing
navigation controller
to appear?
ALEX RUSSELL: No, you
should measure.
You should measure,
measure, measure.
And once you've measured, you'll
have an answer about
whether or not it's
better or worse.
But you won't until
you measure.
JONAS SICKING: So I
think there's two
separate questions here.
Taking resources and storing
them locally on the client
side, I think, it's a good
workaround to do until we get
things like this controller
thing, until we fix AppCache,
until we get other mechanisms in
place that actually make it
a pleasurable experience to
develop these solutions.
So the local storage issue of
being asynchronous API--
please to measure it, but it's
actually really, really hard
to measure.
The problem is that what a lot
of asynchronous IO, which A,
is very, very dependent
on a device.
You can't measure it locally.
You need to measure it on
your users' devices.
The other problem is that it's
not a performance hit that
happens every time you
use local storage.
It happens probably the
first time you see it.
And even just like calling--
we've had some benchmarks that
the first thing it does, it
calls localStorage.clear
and then it
starts using local storage.
But at the time you called the
localStorage.clear, that's
actually when the performance
hit happens.
Local storage, I would say,
is hard enough to measure
performance of that
you probably
will not get it right.
What we're doing in Firefox at
22, 21 or something is we're
actually going to pre-load local
storage before we're
even running scripts.
So that performance hit
is not something
you can't even measure.
And the reason we're doing that
is because hopefully in
those cases, we can do this
IO before we're even
attempting to use it.
It does have the effect that
we're going to do more IO for
each and every page on your
website as soon as you use
local storage.
But that's to avoid halting
the thread and having your
site look up while you're
doing this IO.
So local storage's performance
is really, really tricky.
So IndexDB has issues.
Those are, in big
part, my fault.
I'm one of the editors
for that spec.
We do need something like
asynchronous local storage,
which is as simple as local
storage but doesn't have the
synchronous problem.
So that hopefully
will come soon.
ALEX RUSSELL: I'm hoping
for that, too.
ANDREW BETTIS: OK, so in the
meantime, do you think that
the fact that developers love
local storage and don't like
APIs like IndexDB is an
indication that we need to
simplify IndexDB and Web SQL
and those sort of APIs?
ALEX RUSSELL: Yes, absolutely.
So one of the things that I've
been working on over the last
couple of months is to add
a futures primitive.
So you might have promises
in your libraries.
We're just going to ignore the
fight over what it means to
have a promise.
We're going to call
it a future.
It's a different thing.
Same API.
.then, and then you can add
whatever callbacks you want to
success and failure,
accept or reject.
OK, cool.
So we're building a spec for
futures for DOM, so we can
start to reinterpret a lot of
these asynchronous things in a
more unified way.
Because events aren't really the
right model for something
that is a single request.
If I get one thing out of local
storage, I'm only asking
for one thing back.
I'm not asking for a potential
stream of things to happen
zero or more times in
the future, which
is the event model.
So I have hope that we'll be
able to build a saner version
of a lot of these APIs to stop
using events and stop using
implicit asynchronicity and end
of term behavior and make
it much more explicit in the
APIs, do an asynchronous local
storage on top of something like
this, and then Web Crypto
and IndexDB, I think all these
APIs can be retrofitted with
this model so that we get a
much more rational API.
I think a lot of this is down to
the APIs not really having
great idioms baked into them.
And it's one of these
traditional DOM versus the
rest of the JavaScript world
discussions, which I'm happy
to talk to you about over
beer endlessly.
ANDREW BETTIS: So how long
until we get navigation
controller?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I'm not taking
responsibility for that.
JONAS SICKING: So the space of
fixing the AppCache where
navigation controller is a very
interesting proposal is
something that for some reason
we had a very, very hard time
actually getting to the point
of having proposals.
I would say we've been working
on this for well over a year
and a half, probably two years,
on just people ranting
about how much AppCache
sucks, but there has
not been any proposals.
There are now two proposals.
There's the controller thing.
Mozilla also has a proposal that
we're hopefully going to
present very soon.
And I think that's an enormously
good first step.
What we need to do once we have
these proposals is to get
feedback from everyone
that has been
complaining about AppCache.
The two proposals are actually
very complementary, so they
actually combine very well.
If you had these two
things, would
that solve your problems?
Or would this just be
a less sucky way?
So we have a very
good first step.
It will take a little bit to
get this stuff implemented,
but I think it'll take a lot
less than the well over a year
that we've been complaining
about AppCache.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So on the
simple APIs, do we build
something really low level and
maybe a bit more complicated
to deal with, or do
we just try and go
as simple as possible?
We want something as simple
as possible, but look what
happened to AppCache.
They made something that was
really, really simple, but
they didn't know what people
really wanted to do with it,
so they made some things
simple and useless.
Whereas with local storage, that
was the simple and easy
to use but had massive
performance problems.
So I like the world where you
might have something like
IndexDB, where it's what you can
do with it-- there's loads
you can do with it--
but then have a look at what
the use cases are.
See what code you see people
repeating over and over.
What are people using libraries
for, and how can we
get that into the problem?
You see that happening
with the DOM now.
querySelectorAll was one
of those things.
We see jQuery doing it.
We can make jQuery faster by
having that on the platform,
and people maybe wouldn't
have to use jQuery
if that's the case.
So that's what I see going
with the navigation
controller.
Some of the code that I showed
on there was stuff I made up.
There was a routing function,
which is something that
probably won't be there in the
initial spec, but it's
something you can create
yourself or something a
library can give you.
And we'll be able to see what
people are doing and if
there's common patterns or a lot
of repeated code, then we
can put that in the platform and
make it quicker and make
it less typing.
MARK CHRISTIAN: Yeah, we can
trust that libraries will come
into existence.
It's something that we can
rely on on the web.
So we should build for
flexibility instead of stupid
simplicity.
ANDREW BETTIS: Well,
we're out of time.
So thanks, everyone.
And that's the end
of the panel.
[APPLAUSE]